this is Lily an African penguin  she's a jackass no really  African penguins are commonly known as  jackass penguins their nickname comes  from the donkey like sounds they make  but they're no donkey these little guys  grow up to only a little over two feet  and weigh up to eight pounds they are  only found on the south western coast of  Africa where they are a popular site for  tourists however experts say that if  their population decline isn't stopped  they'll be extinct in 15 years you see  African penguins are pursuit divers and  feed mostly on fish and squid but  because of competition from commercial  fishing they have to go further and  further to find enough to eat that  combined with encroaching human  development poaching for eggs and oil  spills are all taking a toll on its  population this is the African penguin